do you think that there is an impact on
like brands that are like selling
cordyceps do you think that something
like the last of us would like make
people be like I don't want to take that
and put it I'm pretty sure yeah
yeah because
um I didn't drink water after I watched
the movie Waterworld
for like a year
I was like this is too much water I
can't do it you know what I mean so
you're right it has these little logic
checks out right it checks out you know
I mean it's like I think about any movie
you know volcano I didn't go buy a
[__] bonfire for the bonfire you know
how I love camping yeah and I love
walking by bonfires my point is is that
do you like the show